We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine to David p.
This voicemail is from the ag man.
Now I need to give you some background.
The AG man lives in rural upstate New York
and he's told us before that he lives in a
relatively low income area and that he lives
in a quite conservative area and works mostly
with conservatives.
And he left a voicemail explaining the way
that conversations are taking place about
health care premiums going up and his coworkers
and the people around him blaming Obamacare,
which of course makes no sense.
And I'll tell you in a second why take a listen
to this.
Hey Dave, I just wanted to give you a little
hands also on why Democrats are losing.
I just had the quarterly media.
My company, I'm 120 employees or so, a three
owners, um, discussing how the uh, the healthcare
costs are going up next year by three, five,
7%, whatever it is.
He literally blame Obamacare, you said because
of Obamacare.
We're still stuck on the blah, blah blah,
and after eight, so doing the best we can,
it goes up this much.
So you have conservative owners killing stupid
factory workers that Obamacare is causing
me on insurance rates to go up instead of
owning the fact that Donald Trump did not,
uh, fix or change something he swore he was
going to do before he was elected.
So that's how that key would fellow brother.
Yeah, I mean, listen, I don't know if it's
a strategy or ignorance, but I said it [inaudible]
I've been saying this for years.
The states that choose, uh, or let me put
it a different way.
There are states that chose not to do the
Medicaid expansion under Obamacare.
They were mostly red states.
I think they were all red states.
I'm saying mostly because I don't have the
list in my mind.
Um, those states, uh, tend to not have very
good healthcare systems, access cost, all
of that stuff.
And we knew that the residents of those states,
rather than holding their governor accountable
for not doing the Medicaid expansion, we're
going to say I'm in rough shape with regards
to health care because of Obamacare.
Of course the opposite is true.
Your governor opted not to participate in
the expansion of Medicaid in your state.
The problem is ignoring Obamacare, not Obamacare
in and of itself, and there are much bigger
overarching issues that we can talk about
here, including criticisms of Obamacare and
Barack Obama's week starting negotiation point
on Obamacare, but the ag man points out something
really important, which is that narrative
is more powerful than truth and that part
of the reason as he says, that the Democrats
keep losing is that the narratives that Republicans
have spun yes on the backs of ignorant voters,
no doubt about it, are really effective.
This big thing, Obamacare happened and yet
our premiums keep going up.
Obamacare must be the reason, even though
premiums have been going up for decades and
they went up more slowly within the Obamacare
exchanges rather than outside of them.
Glaze over.
Right?
It's too long.
We've already lost the thread as far as that
goes.
So this goes back to you can't convince those
people to vote a different way and I don't
encourage you to try to do it.
I, yeah, I talked to Trump just on the show.
I'm doing a show in my personal life.
I'm not trying to convince people not to support
Donald Trump.
It's a waste of time.
The way to win elections is to get the half
of the electorate that already agrees with
us, but doesn't vote simply to go out and
vote.
That's what we need to do.
And the egg man's anecdote as disturbing and
disheartening as it is, uh, is just more evidence
of that.
We have a tremendous bonus show for you today.
There are some newly released recordings of
Ronald Reagan referring to monkeys from African
countries.
Not Good.
We will talk about that.
A 10 year old boy has been charged with assault
for injuring a classmate in a dodge ball like
game.
We will talk about what's going on there.
And then I have some interesting stories about
this next one.
One in four food delivery drivers reportedly
admit to eating some of your food.
In a recent study, I have some specific stories
involving none other than the delicacy known
as Crab Rangoon, uh, to tell you about regarding
that.
Make sure that you're following me on Instagram
at David.
Dot.
Pacman for video of my tomato plants.
Yes, urban gardening, people up in arms about
all of the ways in which I am incorrectly
pruning my tomato plants.
People have a lot of time on their hands.
That's on my Instagram page at David.
Dot.
Pacman.
Uh, and make sure to get instant access to
the bonus show by becoming a member@joinpacman.com
or at patrion.com/david Pakman show and, and,
and, and uh, make sure you're following me
on twitch at twitch dot.
TV Slash David Pacman.
We did our first
twitch stream this week and, uh, potentially
potentially plenty more where that came from.
We'll speak to you on the bonus show, the
David Pakman show@davidpacman.com [inaudible].